hier j'ai dit lui choisi les arbitres
car oui alors c'est on parle de grains
on parle de grattage qui avait pas et
qui avait dit du mal de moi d'on n'est
pas couché il avait bu j'aimais beaucoup
un pmp ouest est une télé poubelle
donc on dit donc c'est lui qui veut
venir me voir aujourd'hui ça va saigner
c'est bien non et pour de vrai bref
alors il est bien après tout à l'heure
j'ai dit c'est la surprise ça va bien se
passer il est dit attends si ça se passe
mal je viens pas gênant ça va bien se
passer je connais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comédien je suis un petit peu de
comédiens de retour du pire j'ai parlé
de toi je sais que dans des termes peu
élogieux
c'est ça ma finalement ça m'a fait rire
non mais tu sois venu alors avec ses
plaisirs partagés parce que on a pu en
discuter en interne
ouais et c'est cool parce que tu es un
bon gage voit la première fois que tu
nous a accueillis vous étiez avec
orelsan ouais ouais
la première est que nous a accueillis
tout nous a accueillis bienveillamment
c'était cool mais non parce que voilà
j'ai eu des magouilles voilà sûr on
n'est pas couché moi ça va ça m'a vexé
besoin tahitienne télé poubelle et en
plus tout le monde nous attaquer à ce
moment là et pour moi sur ce nous sommes
et voilà chez une émission dont je suis
hyper fier et voilà donc comme quand on
attaque les chroniqueurs quand on
attaque les missions ça me rend fou et
voilà donc ouais j'ai eu et j'ai eu des
mots ce n'était pas l'endroit pour le
faire pour le dire j'ai été piqué la
deuxième fois conduit chez toi mais
j'étais pas là moi je sais que tu étais
pas là mais était piquée parce que on
s'en est pris un petit peu mon pote et
que je suis un peu à orelsan sur les
dents dès qu'on s'attaque à mon pote
hermes qui choisit un jour je n'étais
pas là et on a parlé de la polémique à
orelsan dans une émission où c'est pas
la faute ni minute julien courbet qui me
remplacer une valve a roulé
la prévenue aigrain avait pris la
défense de son pote et moi l'âme en tout
cas moi je suis hyper content que tu
sois venu ce soir et je suis ravi qu'on
encaisse on enterre la hache de guerre
les jours
nous voilà
au héros j'ai juste une question à coder
suis macho taper ou est-ce que tu as
changé de coiffure à cause de moi j'ai
je bosse chez jacques de son jeu
franchement tu veux que je te dise ça me
fait vraiment je suis ça me touche
beaucoup
j'ai eu un coup vraiment plaisir partagé
qu'on puisse en discuter même en plateau
ouais mais vraiment tout dire ça vient
je veux aucun bogey et j'espère qu'ils
ont rien à voir avec orelsan un jour
avec grand-place de jeter en plus je
veux dire c'est que j'étais hyper fan de
vous et je vois ça à la télé je
comprends que c'est par les directions
et voilà ternaire j'ai eu des mots durs
est vraiment être payant parce que
j'aime beaucoup de gars que j'aime
beaucoup orelsan ça m'avait touché et je
suis hyper content que tu sois venu soit
vraiment merci grâce au triplé après des
remerciements